hey America Andy Richter here if you're
like me you've got plenty of downtime
while yourself isolating at home and
like many of you I have been going
through a lot of books these days so I
thought I would share some of the books
I've been enjoying and a few I haven't
been enjoying it's time for Andy's Book
Nook
first up is the gatehouse by Nelson
DeMille you know I've been meaning to
check out this book for a while it's
literally been sitting on my shelf for
years but I never got around to it then
about a week ago I ran out of toilet
paper at my house
desperate I grabbed my copy of The
Gatehouse and boy am i glad I did its
pages were surprisingly thick and soft
and as you can see I'm almost finished
with the book I never wanted to end I
highly recommend it as toilet paper I
give this book four squares out of five
next up is Anna Karenina this is a
classic book but an absolute
disappointment as toilet paper the pages
were too thick and uncomfortably stiff
now if you must use this book as toilet
paper try to find a second or third
edition because they often use softer
lighter paper good rule of thumb
addition two for number two's for this
first edition two and a half squares
next up The Da Vinci Code I mean this
book must have been published by Charmin
because The Da Vinci Code was some of
the best toilet paper I've ever had
absorbing and absorbent I I finished a
copy of this book in one sitting after
accidentally eating some expired baloney
five squares next up this issue of
Vanity Fair magazine now if you think a
high-end glossy magazine would make bad
toilet paper your right eye I would give
it 0 squares but the perfume sandals did
come in handy Vanity Fair 1 squared
well that's about all the books I have
time for but before I go some advice if
you're gonna use a book as toilet paper
for your own personal safety avoid
pop-up books at all costs
back to you counting
[Music]